I can imagine
That even the oldest species of humans,
Or possibly objects before human
They have asked themselves questions
why I am here? What is the nature of existence?
Why is the universe organized in such a way that it is?
And these questions are what we seek to answer them
In physics
Where you can put it
Maybe immediately after math
As the oldest science.
If we have mathematics, where it is very ancient,
And hence on the basis of sports
You have physics.
Physics is really trying to use those maths
Along with some basic ideas
To explain phenomena,
All phenomena,
in the universe.
Physicists are the first to admit
It's just just beginning to understand
The nature of reality, (the universe)
The nature of everything around us.
Now many times, we believe that physics
Confined only to things like cosmic phenomena
Or send missiles into space,
Or how waves move or build structures.
But physics is the basis for
All other sciences.
When we think about chemistry,
Which is the ultimate
Interactions between atoms,
These interactions are really physics-based interactions.
That is why chemistry is actually placed
On a physical basis.
Even when we think of ourselves,
Our bodies, even our consciousness, our brains,
All of this is really about chemistry and physics.
It is summed up in interactions between atoms
And even the mechanical properties of our bodies.
Even biology,
So what we are,
It is built on the foundations of chemistry.
So this is the biology here,
Built on the basis of physics,
Which rely heavily on some mathematics
Which you have been learning all your life
Which you will continue to learn
This fundamental question that I may have asked,
Well you know, "Hey, why am I learning this math?"
, 'The answer is because mathematics is beautiful,
But you too will see it start,
In describing the structure (existence) of the universe.
We are going to see more, more and more
We go on physics
All these complex phenomena
Which we see around us,
If we are looking at a galaxy
Or looking at ocean waves,
Or even look at biological systems,
We will see that the amount of shock (large) of them (mean phenomena)
It can begin to be described using some mathematics to some extent
The mathematics on which we can build
And continue to build on them.
Simple or complex mathematics (higher)
Such as force = mass × acceleration (wheel)
We will talk about strength and acceleration
As directed quantities (vectors).
We will think of things like displacement,
I will put it as a vector quantity,
We'll learn more about vectors soon
And numerical quantities.
Offset = Speed ​​× Time.
We will learn things like acceleration (the wheel)
Wheel = change in speed التغير change in time
You will even see with a little amount
From very simple ideas like these .. But we
We will go deeper into future recordings.
You will be able to expand all kinds of complex phenomena
The only thing I have always loved in physics,
I do not think he is always fully aware,
Sometimes when you begin to learn physics,
You will see all these complex formulas,
All these types of complex problems,
But it is a great value to achieve - it means understanding physics
It comes from some of these basic ideas.
Some of the things I just mentioned,
These ideas, we will discover the laws of energy.
We will learn about Newton's laws.
We will think and explain the types of forces,
And why they are, why they actually exist.
In essence, it's an attempt to
Explain the complexity of the universe,
Predict what will happen
Based on simple ideas.
That's all that physics involves.
Now when we think about physics,
It has been studied by humans for a very, very long time.
In fact, I'm sure we do not know
Who are the early physicists?
But some of the ..,
I think you can tell founding thinkers
In physics. They are the gentlemen I have here.
This is just ...
These are some of the most prominent thinkers in physics
But certainly this is not a complete list
First of all, we want to talk about Isaac Newton.
Especially when starting to study physics,
I have begun to understand the world
As understood by Newton
"He said," Hey,
"Things do not fall to the ground
"Just because it's always so, !!
Just because this is the universe!
There is a force that affects them,
"It is probably the same force that affects me
"To be sitting on my seat now
"Which makes the earth revolve around the sun
"Or the moon revolves around the earth."
I have explained in detail the Law of Attraction,
We will study Newton's laws
We will go into the basics of physics.
We will see and explain
Even classical mechanics (primary,
Physics created by Newton,
Many phenomena can be explained
Stunning accuracy.
But as we progress in the early 20th century,
Physics is more complex
While looking at metrics
A tiny king
Our Max Planck gives us quantum mechanics,
And then we have Albert Einstein
We begin to think very quickly,
The speed of light, we realize it is absolute.
Nothing can move faster than the speed of light,
And this is a puzzling thing
We have these ideas
Public and private relativity,
And we begin to realize that the universe
In some ways more strange, more ambiguous,
And the most wonderful ever we could imagine
But all this work, from Planck and Einstein
To understand modern physics
And they are based on a lot of basic ideas
Which was given to us by Isaac Newton,
Even people before Isaac Newton.
As you deepen your study of physics
I hope to be a physicist.
I wanted to be a physicist.
'Cause it's all, we're all a wonderful miracle,
Why are we here?
What is the nature of reality?
Why are things as they are?
These are questions that physics tries
To answer them
Since you will begin your studies of physics,
I want to leave you with some quotations
Of these three gentlemen.
So the first two of Isaac Newton.
"The truth can not be found in simplicity,
"And not in the multiplicity and confusion of things."
I really wanted to emphasize this,
Because sometimes in your study,
You can find yourself save formulas
Vocabulary, but ..
If you do this, you are too superficial not to want to delve deeper.
But if you really start to think about it,
Think and wonder where these things come from
With time, what you are studying will be easier, easier, and more intuitive.
After that, you will get closer to the truth.
Now, I like this second quote from Isaac Newton.
"I do not know exactly how to look ...
"I also do not know how to appear to the world,
"But for me, I just look like a little girl
"Playing on the beach,
"I pray myself from time to time
"To find a smooth pebble
"Or shell is more beautiful than normal,
While it is a large circumference of facts
"Anonymous for me".
I would imagine that there is a lot we do not know
, Although we believe we know a lot,
So we do not even know a small part about
What the universe really is.
Even a great thinker such as Isaac Newton,
Has admitted this.
It's like "Hey, I'm just a Hao
"On the seashore I pick up a pebble from there,
"But there is this vast ocean
"Which I can not even begin to understand."
You can even imagine exotic civilizations
That thousands of years before us
Technically or scientifically
Or even millions of years,
How they can perceive reality,
And they may see us as ants
We're just beginning
To discover a small part of the universe's realities.
This is from Max Planck.
"When you change the way you look at things,
"Things you look at will look different."
I find that these are very deep,
Because it is truly substantive wisdom.
When studying physics,
You will start to see,
Most of what we consider a reality,
Based on our current understanding
On these forces, but what are these forces?
Even these things that we think are solid,
When we reach the atomic level,
We see that most of them are void
And it's really just a powerful interaction
That makes us believe that something
Solid or material in one way or another.
You are aware of these very concrete things
Not even concrete after all.
In the end, the whole world
It is just a model of our mind.
In some ways,
It's just an illusion
That our mind thinks so we can work.
But we are just beginning to understand it.
last but not least,
There are actually tons of many quotations
Of these people and others,
But especially Albert Einstein.
"The most beautiful experience
"We can go into it is ambiguity.
"It's the core emotion that stands
"In the cradle of real art and real science."
I really want you to take this seriously
While studying physics.
There will be times where you will
We build our kit
What is the vector value?
What is the numerical value?
Going into some math,
Some formats are proven.
That is our kit (our tools)
But then we will try to understand
Basic phenomena.
How does the universe actually work?
And when we begin to think about these,
You will not get a little chills on your skin,
A few cries of horror, you will feel that the universe
Is more mysterious than I thought,
Then we only study physics
Because we have to study them.